for so far nevada's distributed about 1
million coronavirus vaccine doses alex
yeah in a week from today everyone 16
and older will be eligible for the
coveted vaccine here in nevada
bianca holman is live now with a push to
get high risk groups vaccinated
before the expected rush next week hi
bianca
yeah hey alex hey john so here at the
las vegas convention center
they distribute a thousands of doses of
the copic 19 vaccine to folks every
single
week and so right now nevadans 16 and
older who have pre-existing conditions
can get their vaccine and health
officials want those folks
to go ahead and sign up for their
appointment now because in a week it'll
be open up to everybody
and so in addition to those with
pre-existing conditions hospitality
workers teachers and those in the
medical field
can receive the vaccine as thousands of
shots are put into arms daily there's no
word yet on when we'll reach
60 percent vaccination marker but in
order to reach herd immunity as quickly
as possible the health
district is doing all they can to get
people in for their shot and remove
any hurdles or barriers they're still
going to
ask for some patience through this
process of the
availability and the scheduling and
appointments and so we're still going to
be in that place just as we've been
since the beginning of this response
and those who get the fires or modern
vaccine that requires two shots so the
health district is using reminders like
text messages
to get people to return for that second
dose so again if you're eligible
uh 16 and older with the pre-existing
condition or in those specific groups
that we just named
a few minutes ago then again they want
you to sign up for your appointment as
quickly as possible because in a week
it'll be open to everyone 16 and older
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now
bianca thank you very much it is now 6
36. so if you need help making or
cancelling a coronavirus vaccine
appointment
call the number on your screen
1-800-4010
it's available for you from 8 until 8 7
days a week and we have more details
available for you as well
at eightnewsnow.com